right now somewhere out there there's an
educator delivering a mind-altering
lesson to their class I want to engage
your brains and that's try to get my
head round how fast on anything but that
lesson only reaches the students in that
room what would happen if we could
capture that lesson this is a tooth to
be and what if crow animators and
visualization artists could bring that
lesson to life so Jake we see every day
when the tree fit 1 million Earth's it's
got a bunch of notches and it's got a
bunch of teeth this was fees oh solution
when that lesson lands curiosity is
ignited seems impossibly big but that
something interesting happens in the
great scheme of things just a pinprick a
door is starting to close on the light
beam that's coming back to his eye then
that group of students is one thought
closer to being what every teacher hopes
their students will be a lifelong
learner based on the distance between
the two station the quest for knowledge
and understanding he never gets down
doesn't calculates the speed of light to
within two percent of its actual value
the more you know the more amazing the
world seems that's the central mission
antenna to capture and to amplify the
voice and the world's greatest teachers
does this in 18-49 it's the crazy
possibility it's the unanswered
questions pull us forward
stay curious
you